What's your blood type, Alex?
I'm very much aware that in the West,...
...people do not care about, talk about or even know about their own blood type.
But don't you need to know for when you donate your blood or for if you ever need a donation?
How would you know what kind of blood you need in an urgent situation?
I don't think we, as donators, need to know such information.
Speaking of blood type, it was very interesting to see how Korean people, in fact Japanese too,...
...are crazy about knowing other people's blood type.
One disappointing thing about knowing one's blood type...
...is that people prejudge what kind of person you are even before they get to know you better.
I heard that the relationship between blood type and personality...
...hasn't been scientifically or statistically proven.
When I was 19 years old, I did donate my blood at school,...
...but they never told me what kind of blood I have.
I see.
I know mine because I heard it from a hospital when I had surgery to remove my appendix.
I asked them about my blood type because they had to send a sample of my blood to a special institution.
Anyways, I think people shouldn't prejudge others.
Don't judge a book by its cover.
Absolutely.
We never judge people by their looks.
Speaking of the blood type,...
...how on earth do we know their characteristics just by blood type?
I think it's impossible.
I believe blood type should be used for medical purposes only.
No one should be judged by their blood type.
That's nonsense.